Hi, my name is
Dr. Zweibel, and
today we're going
to be talking about
sports medicine
overuse injuries.
We have a few objectives
to cover this session.
First and foremost,
we're going to be
contrasting the
pathophysiology of bone,
muscle, and tendon
overuse injuries.
We're going to be
able to explain
how to diagnose
an overuse injury.
We should be
able to explain
how to treat an
overuse injury.
And finally, I would
like for you to
interpret common
clinical scenarios of an
overuse injury after
we're done today.
let's talk
about some risk
factors for an
overuse injury
really to identify
the diagnosis and
treating overuse injury
we have to figure out
and assess risk factors
that the patient
might have so try
and understand how
they got in the situation
and that includes
both extrinsic and
intrinsic factors if
you don't think about
these factors the
injury will just
continue to happen no
matter what steps we're
taking to treat it
Extrinsic, meaning
outside of the
individual, focus on
factors that you want
to consider such
as training errors.
So this could be some
problem with intensity,
volume of the exercise
they're doing.
It could also be
going too hard on the
exercise, that
means going too high
on your number of
repetitions, too long
on the type of
exercise you're doing.
Commonly we'll see
that if they're
rapidly increasing
how hard or the amount
of time they're
spending exercising,
they can get injuries
coming down a lot.
We can see the different
types of exercises.
So if you're used to
one type of exercise
routine or platform,
and you go to a new one,
this is a common area
we can find injuries.
Technique is
really important.
You want to make
sure the athlete
involved is using
proper form to
prevent injuries
from recurring.
And finally, for
trainers, you have to
give yourself appropriate
recovery time. If
the patient is not
allowing time for their
body to heal, then
it's going to get worn
out and the stress
is going to grow and
grow and that's going
to lead to injury.
Some other things to
think about are the
surface. Is the
surface hard? Is it a
dynamic surface? What
kind of equipment are
they using are they
using appropriate shoes
or footwear and for
the exercise they're
performing the
environment also plays a
role so we want to
know what environment
are they exercising
in is it indoors or
outdoors is it climate
controlled if it's
outdoors is it
excessively humid or cold
all these things
are factors the
clinician should
be reviewing
and discussing
with the patient
intrinsic factors
are things that
are within the
patient themselves
so there could be
malalignment you want to
check to make sure if
there's any difference
in patella heights and
hip angle you all look
at different foot
postures so whether
they're flat-putted or
whether they have an
excessive arch leg length
discrepancy or atomic
irregularities any
weakness or bone or muscle
imbalances you almost
always find these
and they play a large
role some patients are
very flexible or the
opposite they have very
tight muscles and
flexible and this will
impact the type of
exercise they're doing how
effective they are and
the risk for injury.
Lastly,
genetic, endocrine,
and metabolic issues
that have a role to
play, any of these
organic problems that
a patient has are
going to impact
their risk of injury.
So looking at the
complete picture can
really help you identify
why someone's coming
to you with an
injury. When we're
talking about
different types of
overuse injuries,
it's helpful to
break them down
into categories.
The three main
categories we look at are
bone stress injuries,
muscle, and then
lastly, tendinopathies
or tendon issues.
Most stress
reactions or stress
fractures are going
to be occurring in
lower extremities,
so that's where
you're going to be
looking for them.
Most commonly, they're
going to be found
in the young adult
or the 18 to 25
range. There's also an
inverse relationship
between the amount
of lean body mass
and the incidence
of stress reaction.
Women are more
likely to suffer
stress injuries
than males,
about one to two and
up to 10 times more
depending on the literature
you're looking at.
And we'll talk about
why in a little bit.
We also said
lower extremity
makes up about
95% of injuries,
right?
Tibial stress fractures
are going to make
up 50% of all diagnosed
stress fractures.
So narrowing it down
even further, usually
this is due to running,
but not always.
If it is due to
running, usually we're
seeing this in the
middle or distal third of
the tibia on the
posterior medial border.
Alternatively, you can
find stress fractures
on the middle
third or the inner
cortex of the tibia,
and this is more likely
to be associated with
jumping activities.
So basketball,
gymnastics, even dancing
can precipitate this
type of finding.
The way that
scuttle injuries
start is not
always clear,
but it is theorized
stress injuries are due
to fatigue around
the bone, leading to
excessive force, and
thus transmission that
force onto the bones
leading to injury after
that injury there's a
cascade or a modeling
response that ultimately
can lead to a full
fraction so what
happens is we get bone
stress leading to vascular
congestion and some
thrombosis there's
increased osteoclastic
activity or breakdown
of bone outpacing the
osteoblastic activity
or building a bone
and this is going to lead
to weakened trabecular
we can get some micro
fractures and if
the stress is continuing
in the same areas
Ultimately, this is going
to lead to a
full fracture.
Moving on to
some extrinsic
risk factors
specific to a stress
reaction or
stress fracture.
It's things we
mentioned previously,
right? So runners,
we talked about areas
that are specific
stress fractures and
that it's more common
in this population.
It can happen when
they're increasing
their mileage too
quickly or a big increase
in the intensity
of their training.
We can see it when
they move from
one training surface
to another, going
from roads to track
or vice versa.
maybe they're using some
new training equipment.
Some intrinsic factors
of stress fractures
are low bone density,
low BMI, right? So
lower the weight and lower
the amount of skeletal
muscle and bone
density, the higher rate
of stress fractures
and stress reactions.
Dietary deficiencies,
hormonal imbalances,
sleep deprivation,
all these are
specific risk factors
that can cause
stress fractures
or stress injuries.
We talked about and
I mentioned increased
risk in women. And one
of reasons we see this
is something called the
female athlete triad
we can see it here
it consists of the
menorrhea disordered eating
and even osteoporosis
so in a healthy athlete
what we'd see is
a normal menstrual cycle
which is accompanied
by higher energy and
optimal bone health
and as each of these
go into the dysfunction
this can lead to the
situation we know
as a female athlete
triad so that lack of
energy the osteoporosis
we find to lead to a
higher risk of skeletal
injury let's take
a step back and
look at the clinical
presentation as i mentioned
this is commonly going
to happen in the lower
extremity runners
that i talked about
are the highest risk
for stress reaction
or stress fractures
they're a common
population that you want to
think about this in
you're going to see a
crescendo effect so
what does that mean it's
over you so first the
person might report
a dull ache in their
tibia or shin but it's
going to grow and
grow and get more and
more painful eventually
you wind up with
pinpoint pain so pain
that's really localized
and that person leading
them to not be able
to perform their
activities and exercises
earlier on the pain
will decrease with
rest but as time
progresses and nothing
changes and we continue
the the offending
exercise it returns
with less and less
strain on the area
lastly when at the point
where you're having
a stress fracture,
the pain is present
with minimal activity
and can even be
bothersome at night.
So how do we make the
diagnosis in
these patients?
We talked about the
presentation, so
picking up on those
clues there, we can
confirm the diagnosis
with different
modalities. A plain
radiograph or x-ray is low
sensitivity but has
high specificity.
It's usually
not going to be
positive before
four to six weeks.
On the x-ray though,
if it is positive,
we could see some
periosteal reaction.
We can see some
intramedullary
sclerosis, or
we could even
see an obvious
fracture line.
Bone scan is another
modality. It is
positive early
on, even with the
earliest signs of
bone strain, but it's
not good at
differentiating between a
stress reaction or
a stress fracture.
MRI is going to
be your best test
to confirm the
diagnosis of a
stress fracture or
stress reaction.
MRI, though, is
costly, so x-ray
is a really good
initial test, whereas
MRI is going to
be able to better
confirm the
diagnosis for you.
This is another way
to look at the imaging
modalities. On the
y-axis, you have
pain. On the x-axis
is going to be imaging
changes visible. So
not until the point
where we actually have
the stress fracture
are we going to see
x-ray changes happen,
whereas bone scan
changes are even at
the point where we
have a silent stress
reaction, where there's
some initial bone
strain before the point
we even have pain.
We can also compare
and contrast how the
imaging modalities
are going to look
when we have bone
strain, a stress
reaction, and a stress
fracture. So you'll
notice a bone scan is
going to be increased
uptake across the
board. So again,
not great at
differentiating. The x-ray
is only positive when
we are in a stress
fracture situation,
and the MRI will
show a cortical defect
as opposed to just
an increased high
signal when we go
from stress fracture
to stress reaction.
Here we can see
on the left is an
x-ray showing
periosteal elevation.
On the right, we
have an MRI finding
again showing a
stress fracture.
So just different
looks in
terms of what
you might see.
Becoming familiar
with these
images is really
helpful as a
clinician making
a diagnosis.
And on MRI, we can
really see that hyper
-intense T2 signal on
the distal femoral
area showing a stress
fracture there.
General principles
of stress fracture
treatment, it sounds
simple, but the patient
will ask you over
and over again. If it
hurts, you should not
be doing it, right?
You want to listen
to the person's body.
If it's causing
pain, the exercise
they're doing, the
activities they're doing,
there's additional
stress that's taking
place and you're
injuring it further.
On the contrary,
if something is not
painful, you're not
injuring it further.
That's what we
talk about when we
mean relative
rest. For a stress
fracture, we
typically look at a
period of six weeks
of relative rest.
Relative rest meaning
that this particular
area of the body,
that's injured.
However, cross-training,
maintain your fitness
and health throughout
other exercise
and activities that
don't involve the
injured bone is very
useful in preventing
atrophy throughout
the rest of the body.
Bracing can be
helpful. It's been
shown to reduce
time to return to
competition by
almost three weeks.
NSAIDs we
generally avoid.
Acetamethine
would be a better
choice because
NSAIDs have been
shown to hinder
bone healing.
And to bring it back
to where we started,
correcting the
precipitating factors.
Because if the person's
going back and doing
the same things over
and over again, the
same footwear, same
type of activities,
the same improper form
of lack of eating,
low bone removal
entity, or BMI, it's
going to happen
again and again.
So treat the
underlying dysfunction.
That's going to
be really crucial
in making sure
this person doesn't
wind up back
into your office.
From there, we
can move on to
muscle use injuries.
Again, some
underlying
issues going on.
These are typically
secondary to muscle
imbalances. The imbalances
will cause differences
in the length and
strength of the muscle.
and that's going
to contrast
between the
agonist and the
antagonist of a
given joint, right?
You're going to see
differences in overall
muscle function, where
some will get weaker
and some will get
stronger over time. And
this is going to cause
some functional and
biomechanical problems
that's going to
lead to injury. So
three different muscle
injuries we're going
to talk about, focal
tissue thickening and
fibrosis, or your muscle
strain, chronic
compartment syndrome, and
delayed onset muscle
sores focal tissue
thickening and fibrosis
so muscle strain like
i was saying this is
happening for micro
trauma to the muscles
there's damage to the
fibers from being
overused the damage leads
to the formation of
cross linkages in
the fascia and adhesions
between the muscle
fibers this is making
the muscle less effective
as you could imagine
and you feel these
when you're palpating
your patients you
might notice tight
bands within the muscle
and typically
they're going to be
arranged in the
direction of the stress
and we can have large
areas of increased
muscle too so layman's
terms people might
come in noting that
they have knots in their
muscle so that's what
we're really talking
about when we have
thickening fibrosis
and these are responsible
for pain predisposition
to injury of the
nearby structures
and muscle so injury
of the tendon decrease
ability of contraction
of the muscle and
relaxation in a rapid
manner that you might
need as you're exercising
more intensely.
These are not terribly
hard to treat, although
the longer something
has been present,
the longer it's going
to take before it fully
resolves. So we can
implement stretching,
strengthening,
OMT, all these
can be helpful in
improving muscle
strength and
correcting those
muscle imbalances.
And similar to
bone strain and our
stress fracture
picture, it's a
cascade of increasing
damage from
increasing strain
on the tissue.
So with overuse, we get
some gross tightness
in muscle and fascia.
When that continues,
we see microscopic
damage, then adhesions,
and the fascial cross
linkages. Further
along, we notice
tightness and tension in
the muscle, even more
so than initially.
We get more pain,
more lack of function,
decreased functional
ability of
those muscles, and
we can have damage to
the surrounding
tissues, as we said.
And unless we change
the underlying dynamics
of the situation is
just going to continue
to worsen and worsen
moving on let's talk
about chronic compartment
syndrome really
compartment syndrome is
due to muscle overuse
and it's intermittent
the key thing
here is the reversible
elevation of the
compartment pressure
in the specific
area of the extremity
this is most
likely going to be
following desertion
commonly we'll see
this in the lower leg
although it can happen
elsewhere specifically
in the forearms
some activities you
might find this
happening is in tennis
rock climbing and
weight lifting for the
forums especially and
the reason we have
these compartments
in these extremities
is that they're
inelastic fascial
sheaths the sheaths
are not going to
allow for expansion
when we have
increased muscle
tone and muscle use
and we'll explore
what happens there
so the exercise raises
the intercompartmental
pressure you
might get some
muscle swelling you
get accumulation
of fluid in the
interstitial. And like
I said, the fascia
is going to prevent
the expansion that
you would need.
Because it's inelastic
and won't expand,
you get impaired
blood flow and
compression of the
neurologic function.
Typically, what you'll
see is pain on exertion.
All these things,
the blood flow,
neurologic
stressors, muscle
hypertrophy will
contribute to that.
Like we said, lower
leg is most common. So
it's important to
recognize some the
structures and
compartments in the lower
extremity the anterior
compartment where you
have the dorsiflexus
with an ankle there's
a lateral compartment
where we focus on
eversion and planar
reflection deep posterior
is involved in planar
reflection inversion
and the superficial
posterior so the
gastrocnemius soleus
the largest compartment
lower leg involved
in plantar flexion
What are you going to
be seeing when this
patient walks in?
The patient's going
to be telling you that
they're experiencing
pain and pressure
in the extremity.
They're going to
note that pain and
pressure is going
to begin with the
activity and is
continued throughout the
exercise, but
dissipates with rest.
So it starts to improve
as they're resting.
One thing you can do
to make the diagnosis
is measuring the
compartment pressures.
This can be done at
rest or it can be
done during exercise,
either or. And what
happens is that catheter
is placed inside
the muscle of the
suspect a compartment,
the person exercises
until you get
symptom reproduction,
and you measure the
different compartments
and see if there's
a true pressure
elevation going on.
What do we do for this?
Early on, and most
of the time, what
you're going to
do is conservative
management. So again,
OMT, stretching,
correction of underlying
abnormalities,
physical therapy,
strengthening.
Fasciotomy is
going to be the
ultimate treatment,
though, if those
conservative
treatments fail.
and in fasciotomy
what you're doing is
you're releasing the
fascia surgically like
what you're seeing
on the right hand
side of your screen
in that picture there.
Last but not least in
overuse of muscles is
the late onset muscle
soreness or DOMS for
short. We've all felt
this before. This is
the pain and soreness you
experience approximately
one to two days after
you're exercising.
Usually if you're
trying a new exercise or
something you haven't
done in a long time.
It's especially
severe after eccentric
exercises. So that's
contraction while
there's lengthening
of the muscles.
Those eccentric
movements are going to be
when you get the
most severe DOMS. The
pathophysiology of this
is thought to be due to
muscle fiber damage
and some cell membrane
swelling. Then you
get decreased force
and increase in passive
tension muscle, so a
little bit of weakness
in the short term.
Fortunately, this
does go away quickly.
Treatment is really
active recovery.
Continuing to do
some exercise the
best you can.
Stretching, NSAIDs, OMT,
Ice baths can
be helpful by
constricting some
of the blood flow.
Finally, tendon
overuse injuries.
Tendinopathy is
the main one here.
What are you seeing
in tendinopathy?
It's a pretty typical
picture in these
patients. You're
going to see pain with
the use of the
affected area in the
morning that's
localized to the tendon.
Usually when they're
resting, they're
pain-free.
And what happens is
they'll tell you that
when they're exercising,
the pain starts.
But as they get
warmed up in the
exercise, the
pain is going to
decrease and
commonly, typically,
is going to go
away completely.
Then as the patient
starts going down
again, they experience
the pain once more.
On physical exam,
you might notice
some tenderness
locally in the
area of the tendon
and the thickening
of the tendon
that's affected.
Another common thing
patients might tell
you is that when
they're laying down
on that side, they
have pain in the
area. So if you have
tendonitis to the
shoulder, you might
hear the patient saying
when they're lying
down on their
shoulder at night,
it's painful to them.
Now,
in tendinopathy, there's
actually
different stages.
The earliest stage
is what's called
reactive tendinopathy.
And just to be clear,
all of tendinopathy
is non-inflammatory.
It's a response to
the tendon cells.
And the tendon cells
are typically almost
like steel cables
and steel wire, like
in a high tension
wire. They're parallel,
they're close together,
neatly organized.
So when these tendons
get overworked, the
tendon cells activate
and proliferate,
and they produce
proteoglycans that are
supposed to repair the
tendons themselves.
And so initially
what happens is
you get thickening
of the tendons.
But what happens if
this continues and the
strain continues on
the tendons themselves?
Then you're going to get
some tendon disrepair.
This is when the
tendon matrix starts
to break down.
The tendon cells
are going to
predominate and become
rounded and
chondrocytic. You can see
myofibroblasts
really proliferating
in this stage
also. There's
more proteoglycans
and we get
disorganization of
that matrix. So you
can see in this picture
here, there's really
less and less parallel
structures and
the parallel type
fibers are needed to
have proper force when
you're contracting.
And what happens
is you will get
this disorganized
matrix and soon you
get blood vessels
and nerves in the
tendon, which
should not be there.
And that's going
to cause further
disrepair. And as
we continue down
the cycle, we
eventually wind
up with degenerative
tendinopathy.
This is progression
from stage two. And
in degenerative
tendinopathy, we get
apoptosis of the normal
cells. We get large
areas of disorganization
and more and more
neovascularization,
matrix breakdown. So
there's little remaining
normal collagen,
a lot of breakdown
products, and not
a well-functioning
tendon in any sense.
So this is what
we're really talking
about put all
together. If you look
on the right side
of the screen, you
can see that in
picture A, there's a
normal tendon,
parallel, longitudinal,
few elongated
tenocytes, nice looking
tendon. When we go to
B, we have tenopathy,
there's increased
cellularity of
rounded tendonocytes.
We get disorganized
collagen. It does
not look like that
parallel structure
we have on the left.
On your left-hand side
of the screen, it's
just another visualization
of what can happen
when tendons undergo
stress. And keep
in mind, if we optimize
the load and we have
a normal tendon, the
tendon is going to
adapt and strengthen.
What we're talking about
here is overuse and a
maladaptive response,
where there's increased
load, excessive
load, reactive tendinopathy,
tendon disrepair,
and then a degenerative
tendinopathy.
How do we diagnose
this? Usually
you can diagnose
tendinopathy based
on the examination,
the physical
exam, and the
patient symptoms.
There's that
pattern of pain
we talked about earlier.
We'll see that with
tendinopathies.
You can do imaging
on ultrasound.
On imaging, you might see
some hypoechogenicity,
increased size and
thickness of the
tendon. Treatment,
again, is going to be
conservative for the
most part. Physical
therapy, OMT, changing
the type of exercises.
Sometimes you can do
injections, although
you do not do steroids
in the tendon,
due to the risk of
tendon eruption.
Sometimes you will
need to operate if
you have a full
thickness tear or if the
patient fails,
conservative therapy.
So in this case,
you can do tendon
augmentation or tendon
transfer, but only if it
reaches that point.
Really, conservative
therapy is going to
be the mainstay here.
Next, I want to
present a case to you.
We have a 53-year
-old male, Mr. A. G.
He has icky right
pain in his right
elbow with the
lateral aspect. That's
non-radiating of
two months duration.
Pain has been
gradual, worsening,
and now it's a 7
out of 10 severity.
He is a bowler, going
three to four times a
week, and when he's
bowling, he's noticing
more and more pain. No
numbness, no tingling,
no swelling, or
redness of the joint.
Being the good
clinician you
are, you are an
ultrasound, and
you see this
image right here
based on the
presentation the
image which of
the following is
the most likely
diagnosis if
you chose lateral
epicondylitis you
are correct so to
go over findings
from that ultrasound
what we see is our
common extensor
tendon coming off
the lateral epicondyle
of the humerus
as i mentioned
earlier we can see
hypoechoic defect in the
common extensor tendon
it's an area darker
than the surrounding
and in the arrow
all the way on the
left is your radio
joint line. So that
can give you a
landmark anatomically.
Lateral epicondylitis,
like most
tendinopathies, is a
chronic tendinopathy rather
than an acute
inflammatory process.
What happens is
repetitive or explosive
athletic movements
involving eccentric motion
in which the muscle
tendon union is
lengthened while contracting
can lead to ease.
Commonly, it's going
to happen in the
extensors most commonly
the extensor carpi
radialis brevis it
can happen due to any
of the extensors
though sometimes it's
called tennis elbow as
you might have heard
you might see it in
racket sports thus the
name but it does not
have to be from tennis
or a racket sport
it can occur from a
lot of different
activities pain is going to
be achy and the patient
will commonly note
the pain radiating
down the forearm pain
is often worse with
wrist extension and
that makes sense as the
extensors are engaged
when we extend the
wrist what you can do
to prevent this is focus
on proper mechanics
in the sport or
exercise they're playing
and minimize the
risk of recurring
epicondylitis when we
move to the medial side
medial epicondylitis
this is involving the
flexors of the wrist
and forearm commonly
we're going to see
is affecting pronator
teres and flexor
cartiradialis these muscles
originate at the
medial epicondyle thus
causing medial epicondylitis
pain is commonly
going to be noted
with resisted flexion
this is commonly
associated also with
golfing and pitchers
and baseball do the
strain on the medial
elbow but does not
have to be these sports
exclusively in up
to 20 percent of
athletes you will see
ulnar nerve symptoms
associated medial
epicondylitis so
something to be aware of
Let's go to a few
questions. We have 44 year
old female presenting
to the clinic
complaining of intermittent
right forearm pain
and pressure at three
months duration. Pain
is achy and tight with
occasional numbness
that is present when
she plays tennis
and subsides
immediately after.
What's the most
likely diagnosis? What
we're looking for here is
chronic compartment
syndrome.
What you should be
clued in on is the
intermittent right
forearm pain and pressure.
You get some numbness
that's present when
they play but subsides
immediately after.
Not your typical picture
of a tendinopathy.
really a better
description of what
you see in a chronic
compartment syndrome.
So chronic
compartment syndrome
would be the
correct choice here.
Same setup.
What would be the
best initial treatment
for the patient we
just spoke about?
Physical therapy or
conservative interventions
would be the best
treatment here.
The compartmental
measurement
would aid in
diagnosis, but that's
not what the
question is asking.
Gashiotomy would
be if conservative
measures fail, then
we would choose that
choice. but physical
therapy would be the
best initial treatment
for someone with
chronic exertional
compartment syndrome.
A 22-year-old male
presents the clinic
with right shoulder
pain reading to the
anterior upper arm.
On physical exam, when
the shoulder is
flexed and internally
rotate, externally
rotate with the thumb
pointed up, and there's
resisted downward
pressure, the pain is
reproduced. What do
you expect to find
in histopathology? A
few things to think
about here. The setup,
you should be thinking
about tendinopathy,
specifically in this
case, supraspinatus
tendonitis the
physical exam maneuver
described here is the
full can test so you're
resisting abduction
of the shoulder so
you're putting downward
pressure on the arm
while the patient is
trying to ab duck the
empty the full can test
empty can would just
be the thumb pointed
down and either way
this test looks at
the same muscle group
uh the rotator cuff
and if it's positive
you're thinking
tendinopathy now that you're
thinking tendinopathy
what should you be
expecting on
histopathology like we know
before this is not an
inflammatory process
instead we get
disorganization disrepair of
the tendon so the
correct answer here would
be neovascularization
same setup which of
the following treatments
should be avoided
correct answer here
is d corticosteroid
injection that being
because as we said before
injecting a steroid
into a tendon
can cause tendon
rupture so
it should generally
be avoided
in summary now you
should be able to
contrast the pathophysiology
of bone muscle
and tendon overuse
injuries you should
be able to know
how to diagnose the
different overuse
injuries and treat them on
a basic level you
should be able to
interpret a common
clinical presentation to
the pain patterns of
how the patients are
presenting with those
overuse injuries
The core references
are listed here,
and if you have any
feedback, feel free
to click on the
link and share it
here. Thank you so
much for your time.